[Music]
there was a jet skier
okay thank you
good sadness that was a good sign he um
he was drowning
okay in a in a plate
he was like oh
that was good that was good very nice i
got an interpretive dancer with me here
we go
so he um he's drowning
in in a south korea in a south
carolinian lake
south korea south carolina south korea
nah i like south korea let's do
something south carolinian let's do
something keep
swapping from a redneck to a k-pop star
[Laughter]
so he's he's drowning and a boater pulls
up
and rescues this guy
and then the guy starts going [ __ ]
crazy on him you mean the guy that
drowned the guy who was drowning so he
gets his life saved by this kick him off
the boat i'll push him push him off is
it because he's homophobic and he gave
him cpr and he goes get off me
oh
or is he a somali pirate
no oh that's interesting listen listen
i'm the captain now
they go over there sometimes yeah so the
good samaritan
good samaritan spots
um this guy and his wife
both struggling right pulls up in the
boat gets them on board then the guy
just starts to attack
him
does he push him back overboard uh no he
pulled a gun and shot him which one the
the jet skier the jet the rescuer guy
shoots the jet ski guy i like his style
holy [ __ ] yeah blows his [ __ ] head
off
so it was like no
that's exactly what
that's what it says you're good man
so he says that he didn't know what to
do because the guy was going so crazy
and they're in the middle of the [ __ ]
water and international waters though
it's okay it's leaves exactly right
international south carolina
is legal right scary dude that happens
in the water too i thought that was only
a hitchhiking thing
that's like the hitchhiker thing where
you're like or this or is this guy
playing like oh i'm drowning someone
help me please and then he to go on
that's how you jack boats yeah that's
that he maybe the jet skier was a
smalling pirate this whole time
maybe that's the cover i love the
cockiness of your city they're just like
what are your theories ahead guys i gave
mine what are yours
[Laughter]
somalian pirates so the guy who shot the
other guy he's like yeah the guy was
like pissed off
for saving him yeah he's like take me
back to my [ __ ] jet ski and then he
shoves the guy's wife the boater guy
who's white
and then he's like he said there's snot
and foam coming out of his nose and
mouth
and uh he felt like he had to he felt
like the guy was trying to take control
of the boat like he broke the kill
switch he was making the rabies so he
can't move it whoa and he just wanted to
get to his jet ski he kept on talking
about getting back to his jet ski and so
he fires a warning shot
he pulls out his gun he fires a warning
shot and then he pistol whips the guy
who grabs a hold of his arm and then
they had a little scuffle and then he
shoots the guy in the chest so he
probably was on like drugs maybe maybe
they need an autopsy report unless he
just dumped him overboard and said i
don't want a dead body and then wrote an
article about it
that's wild when you hear stories like
that because like it's only the
survivor's account yeah that's true well
apparently he was drinking truly extras
which is uh that can be red flag red
flag dude what's that red flag foul play
the blueberry truly um they have this
new one called extra or it's like it's
got a little more of a kick it's got
more of a kick
so
what was a guy doing jet skiing alone
he's a truly ad you guys he's truly
he wasn't alone he was with um he was
with the chick oh so the jet ski guy was
with the
with the girl
the boater was alone yeah oh no the boat
was with his wife and the the jet ski
guy was with his chick
oh
oh what did the jet skier's chick say
about it she was she was confused why
why he was being a weirdo and i mean she
was trying to have his back because he
wanted to get back to his jet ski but
then once the struggle started she was
like what the [ __ ] and there was like a
huge argument about everything
wow
maybe he started flipping out because
his girlfriend didn't save him and
that's why he was upset he's like you
bet you didn't have my [ __ ] back you
have my back why did you save me from
drowning his girlfriend wasn't drowning
um what's that his girlfriend wasn't
drowning huh
no she was struggling they were both
struggling but he was having a worse
time than her so it's like doesn't say
older this guy [ __ ] saved them and
then he's like mad that they saved them
the the the people who saved them were
70 years old and then uh oh [ __ ] i can't
tell how old the other people were but
yeah it was
the guy had a kid i guess the guy who
died had a 10 year old son oh
and there's a there's a toxicology um
report being done because they obviously
think that he's on drugs
truly extra
that [ __ ] gets you crazy dude
you need to take that off the shelves
dude
alcohol it's like the modern bath salt
it's wild out there
because a lot of people were already
struggling with regular truly yeah
you think it's on some like weird like
seizure type [ __ ] that's some fentanyl
[ __ ] right there yeah where i don't know
if it was like not saying like something
in the water but if too much went into a
system or he was like a near-death
moment there's some sort of like is this
hallucinating yeah i think some people
are just massive [ __ ] their whole
lives and then that's just the point
where they [ __ ] met the immovable
object
i do have to say that they did find a
blunt
in his car well that should relax him
yeah but he didn't smoke it maybe we all
know isn't it that's probably what it is
he probably is
like it makes a psycho reefer
stories like this where someone's
willing out that that's the [ __ ]
first offense like i bet you this dude's
done [ __ ] like that all the time and
people are like he's irrationally raging
and then this was just the guy that shot
him like or what if they were like
arguing and then they went and fell and
he was already in a state of rage that
could be he was probably [ __ ] weird
because you could see guys like that in
the club all the time oh you're like oh
your [ __ ] your days are numb bro like
something wrong you're gonna die one day
and i'm sure the near-death experience
didn't really help the whole situation
he sounds like who knows he's all his
shit's elevated yeah everything's
probably just so and then he's doing
peach mango trees
about it dude
and he's doing peach mix
that's the culprit
stick to blunts man that's too dangerous
six percent alcohol eight percent my bad
i said twelve the normal ones are like
six this is like we're talking about
some serious [ __ ]
that's a threat to society sorry guys i
said 12 earlier in the video i meant
eight sorry redacted yeah reduction
editor can you
have you guys ever driven like boats
yeah around the lake yeah i love it it's
just so fun how can you never take us
i think that's another one of your rich
stories no it's it's not you just it's
like you have a golden boat or something
no i just like because you're like
people are just going hella fast and so
if you know what it feels like to not
have uh
traffic lights you don't like you're
just going you don't need a boat license
no you just go and you're [ __ ] going
ham and then you look over there you're
like oh [ __ ] i'ma crash into this family
so everyone just kind of slows me up
and everyone's just kind of like you
gotta use a lot it's like driving in
asia just gotta kind of like use common
sense a little bit and then if you jump
off and you go swim around and you're
like i could have sworn the boat was
here but the boat will just drift off
too that's why they got anchors dog no
but they don't give you the anchor
the best part for bart is there's no
poor people around
when you're on regatta he's looking for
some poor people to drown dude looking
for some hydro bumps we should
in lake communities you can get duis
driving a boat drunk yeah
yeah oh yeah but they're all rich anyway
so
and security is super interesting like
all my neighbors have boats which is
like i feel kind of left out because i
don't have a boat yet but then yet but
my uh my neighbors like
every time that he's out there he told
he he goes out there fishing but he
you're not allowed to keep the fish you
can only just fish and like hurt them a
little bit and then put them back in
their mouth why can't you eat the fish
you're on the
hoa thing you can't do it yeah and then
there's security out there and he says
they always check on who's in all the
boats so it's kind of a pain in the ass
a little bit where it's like you're in
the boat and like is it no who are you
or is it this kind of boat
they have they have all those out there
they have ore in there though
it's a batter
i don't know this one
cavehole eve they have those okay yeah
yeah i want to i want to learn how to
sail that's the next level rich boy i do
want to learn how to sail that looks
funny you ever seen those hawaiian dudes
in the canoes yeah that looks tiring we
should do that that should exhaust i
don't want the tiring one i want like
the rich white man
you want to roll crew just all of us
together bro let's just do that i want
to wear some [ __ ] loafers boat shoes
i want us to wear polo and like an ascot
and compete with other crews out there
or do you want to get one with the sail
but you still just have a motorcycle
yeah yeah yeah yeah we'll be the bad
boys
for that yeah your sailboat's loud as
[ __ ] and i feel like sailing is like a
classy sport it's james but we'll start
talking [ __ ] to everybody oh yeah [ __ ]
you your boat sucks you know buying
drinkers yeah yeah we'll throw trulies
at them and [ __ ] remember the first time
we went sailing with our buddy and then
um the engine cut and you didn't know
how to turn it back on yeah and we had
to go back
and the wind was so [ __ ] weak that
day we were moving like slower than a
grandma walking
that [ __ ] was so slow dude we're just
waiting for the [ __ ] grab my walking
speed huh hell yeah dude dude that's
like have you guys seen pictures from
mount everest in video like where
there's it's like a log jam up there
yeah the stairway yeah it's like
everyone's going like grandma speed up a
mount everest yeah when it's cold it's
still dying still dying getting wrecked
there's frozen bodies up there oh yeah
hella they can't get them down yeah yeah
that's pretty cool yeah it's nice to
leave them yeah honestly hey that one uh
recent next netflix documentary with the
guy like a son it's all 14 of the higher
teen peaks yeah nells or something yeah
nails or nouns
he was just not rogan right that guy
men's palm was he then i saw a guy that
climbed a bunch of mountains i was on
salon i don't want to say his name wrong
because he's so cool but i said it wrong
already it's all right
[Music]
[Music]